[Music]  [Applause]  graduation i told you i was going to  drive a dad  this party is about to get  [Applause]  i need a burrito  [Music]  no one will really know what we did  did anyone see us that night  no why do you ask  even if someone knows what happened they  can't prove it  i'm telling you more people are going to  die  this can't be a coincidence  i think that she might be the killer  you're just trying to save yourself  i don't think any of us know what we're  really capable of  we were all the worst people i know  holy fake  sociopath  drug addict  all you do is lie  you had sex with the one person  hello  everything was fine until she came back  she's not really though she was  i need to tell the truth  what if i don't know the truth  there is no redemption in this life good  it's brutal out here  [Music]  you